[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in mike trico joins us from
oh kentucky derby
man that looks great what turn what turn
are you in there mike
this is our set this is turn one nice
when spires are here which fire's over
my shoulder yeah and the twin spires are
my answer to the trivia questions
both
hit and pitch how great is that i agree
you guys do that
hey
i hope somebody from the sox is
listening
fenway should give him that number 17.
the 17 he knocked off the board he
should get to put up in his man cave
wherever that might be that was awesome
i love that that was really cool it's
just that sound there's certain sounds
in sports mike and and when the ball
leaves ohtani's bat
it's different than just about anybody
in baseball there's certain guys like
you cover golf there's certain guys when
they hit a golf ball and you go there
that's different
that's been tiger for a long time fred
couples hit the most solid ball contact
all the time uh john daly you know those
guys when they hit it it just sounded
different and that's still that's still
the case for sure so that scoreboard
fenway reminds me dan have you ever been
inside the scoreboard there
or at wrigley i have an annual
scoreboard at fenway but not wrigley
okay that's i've always wanted to do
that the only one of those that i've
ever had the chance to visit at the
british open which is now known as the
open uh they had manual scoreboards
forever and i got to go up in one i
think one of my last ones in espn or one
of my first ones at nbc and it's just
really really cool to be inside those
iconic and held scoreboards or hate
operated scoreboards and i've always
wanted to go to fenway and check that
one out too is there a comparison for
the kentucky derby sports wise
indy the indy 500 because it's the same
place every year uh different from
augusta because augusta has that
singular location and you know
everything about it but this is a little
bit different because there's you know
millionaires over my shoulder and then
you know across the other side of the
track
it's a mosh pit of people and they have
no idea what's going on in the race
that's the case in indy with the snake
pit uh same kind of deal so i think
those are the most like comparisons the
derby will probably be 150 000 people
here tomorrow and at the end of the
month when we go to indy when it's over
250 and now that we get everybody back
to full attendance post pandemic
are you giving a heads up on who might
show up there celebrity wise tomorrow
uh a little bit not as much this year at
least i haven't yet i'll get a better
idea as the day goes on you know brady
shows up aaron rodgers shows up i don't
know which of the quarterback club or
how many of them are going to show up
this year but
what the one thing that this has always
been good about is guys can go
and they can kind of hang and hide in
the suites with their guys you know i
know aaron's brought some offensive
linemen some receivers over the years
brady's brought gronk edelman and if
they find us a place in the space up
there
most of the other people have
great money great resources great
celebrity so they can hang without being
disturbed
uh nearly as much as you would in some
other sport events that's kind of cool
mike tarico joining us let me give the
full introduction he's uh the voice for
sunday night football he's hosting the
kentucky derby and uh tomorrow at 2 30
eastern on nbc and peacock is when it
starts i'm fascinated by bob bassett bob
baffert
that he's
got a two-year ban but he's got two
horses in the kentucky derby but he's
not allowed to be on on on site
is that correct
yeah uh so the suspension that he has
is a two-fold suspension the kentucky
horse racing commission so they're the
one of the 38
groups that put out the rules state by
state the rules in new york are
different from california different from
kentucky and so on from the other
jurisdictions where horse racing happens
38 of them they don't all operate under
the same rules
but they'll almost in a reciprocity
manner honor
uh suspensions so kentucky suspended
bathroom for 90 days through july 2nd
which covers the triple crown races
so new york and maryland are going to
pick up on that suspension now
separately churchill downs which is
independent from the horse racing
commission in kentucky have said for two
years you can't run at any of the tracks
we own
so he couldn't come here and he can't
have derby horses so these two horses
that he has
uh messier and teba are both gonna run
but he transferred them to a different
trainer in early march and
can't have contact with that trainer
during the process
could he buy a ticket
no uh no he's i think he's banned from
the grounds and he's banned from
training i don't know if he would buy a
ticket and sit in the stands necessarily
but he wouldn't be given a spot on
millionaires rose my guess from the
folks in church
what's the best story at the kentucky
derby this year
you know i think it's
two trainers of the two favorites steve
asmussen is one of them he's the trainer
of epicenter that's the three horse he's
won more races than anybody in north
america he's never won the derby and
chad brown is the other guy he's as good
a trainer as there is save for bafford
he trains number 10 zanden zan didn't
like brandon he's the favorite along
with epicenter brown's never won a
kentucky derby so it's like that
uh
you know bill shelf has won everything
but a national championship gets there
and finally wins it one of those kind of
field to those two guys they're
excellent they are among the best in
their sport but they haven't won the
biggest one that's what is probably the
best storyline in addition to the too
bad for horses
uh rain
right now close to 50 percent
yeah it's supposed to be pouring right
now i thought it was going to be awful
here uh but it's better now i think
we're going to dodge a little bit today
tomorrow looks dry cold but dry so
that's going to affect my seersucker
linen suit i have to go to a different
suit
i really don't care about the horses and
the muddy of course
yes of course yes mike chirico joining
us he is the uh new voice for uh sunday
night football play-by-play help me
understand the end game with the nfl
that now we're going to germany for a
game with seattle and tampa bay we've
been in london for a long time we've
been in mexico city
i wondered mike with 17 game schedule
i get that i get that extra game that i
can sort of play with if i'm the nfl and
then i'm not taking away
your your home games you're still going
to get eight home games
but i don't know where we're going with
this other than
let's broaden our reach
what's the end game
yeah you know the whole thought of can
you put a team in london i think when
you start to look at okay guys get cut
you've got to bring in a kicker on a
friday or something like that i don't
know how feasible it is to have an
entire team for an entire season in
london i thought that was part of the
end game and i don't know if it still is
i do like the fact that they've given
countries teams or vice versa they've
given teams countries hey cardinals and
other teams mexico is your area so go
promote let them fall in love with the
team and then we'll see if you can take
that one game someplace every year the
jaguars have actually built up some sort
of a following in london because they go
every year uh just like look at look at
the premier league
my son is a huge chelsea fan there are a
ton of chelsea fans here in the us so
you can build that now can the nfl build
that in these seven or eight countries
that we know want to watch american
football that's the end game to me
i was also uh
curious your take on name image and
likeness you have the sec in the pac-12
going to washington d.c it's almost like
there's a tax loophole that everybody's
going to take advantage of before they
realize we got to stop this tax loophole
six months from now um where where are
we headed with name image and likeness
the first race just started
i couldn't hear you the horses were
going by um in all seriousness i
look
mark emerick didn't do a good job as the
head of the ncaa i don't think there's
any way you could argue that he was
significantly impactful in a positive
way but this is the worst time to have a
lame duck there for the rest of the year
and then somebody new coming in figuring
out where's the furniture what can i do
college athletics is so screwed up right
now name imagine like this they just
said hey let's go go figure it out now
they're trying to rate it back in you
know should players be getting
compensated yes but should it be used to
recruit players
if that's the case we're only going to
have a certain number of people playing
here's the question i got
does it tie into the mission of your
college university in any way are they
going to school are they any part of
what you do if not then let's go have
minor league sports somewhere and keep
college sports
we had a chance to find a balance and
nobody was in charge at that point when
it needed to happen and i don't think
you're going to get the genie back to
the bottom what i'm worried about
six eight teams are great but are we
gonna have 40 or 50 that can compete in
football that's what makes football
really good and i don't think we're
going to have them anymore
yeah i wonder if you just get a
billionaire who decides that i want my
school to be relevant
let's say it's a billionaire who donates
to tulsa
and imagine if elon musk wanted to spend
money on the university of pennsylvania
football team and just said
hey i'm gonna
i'm gonna spend 15 million dollars here
but you know i want my team to be
relevant
no i if if uh if somebody who's an alum
of a school is like that look look at
what
the nike presence has done for oregon in
all sports facilities everything else i
mean
you now will go to eugene from la from
phoenix from all the geographically
populated areas in the west coast
because of the nike gear because the
facilities because it's cutting edge in
state of the art in so many ways and
that's what a boosters impact can have
now
as opposed to a company and through the
donations to the university it's right
to the kids so why not i say that elon
musk should try that i'm thinking
syracuse are dating
come give our schools a bunch of money
and we'll see if it works if we're going
to play let's play in the big leagues
right why not uh do you have a goofy
looking outfit tomorrow it feels like
it's uh open season when you go to the
derby you can wear something that you'd
never wear again
never i come back every year so i i i'm
kind of basic the tile be okay they
asked me to put on a hat for the today
show i showed up like this in a ball cap
like this is it's the best i can do i
don't look good in hats do you look good
in like no men's hat
yeah i don't either i put it on for the
today show for like two minutes it
looked awful but i did it for the wait
for roker and for the gag why why did
they want a hat on you
because i was with dylan dreyer and
she's wearing a hat and a fascinator and
you know everybody tries my wife's
coming for the first time and she has
hats in the hotel room she's trying on
different hats that's a disaster i told
her i said you better learn how to bet
you better win money because we're
spending a lot of money on hats you're
never gonna wear at this point but uh
it's it is cool you know it is it's a
real party and most of the people here
aren't dialed into the biggest sporting
event in this sport for the year and
those who are i love it and it's one of
the rare places that everybody can play
in the same sandbox
good to talk to you buddy uh have fun
tomorrow come here thank you mike
you got it that's uh mike chirico
joining us turn one there kentucky derby